[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
nächste Woche wird es laut am Himmel
über Deutschland
Kampfflugzeuge teils im Tiefflug daran
ist man hierzulande kaum noch gewöhnt zu
Zeiten des Kalten Krieges bis in die
1990er Jahre hinein war es ja fast
normal das Kampfjets im Übungsflug über
einen hinweg bretterten bis zum
Durchbrechen der Schallmauer nach dem
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion und der
deutschen Wiedervereinigung wurden
solche Übungsflüge massiv reduziert
manche einer der in den 90er oder 2000er
Jahren geboren ist wird das nun nächste
Woche vielleicht sogar zum allerersten
Mal erleben bei der größten Übung
westlicher Luftstreitkräfte seit der
Gründung der NATO Details zu dieser Show
of force gab es heute in Berlin mattes
Feldhoff Bericht
es sind Flugzeuge wie diese russische
Kampfjets und russische
spionageflugzeuge fotografiert von
deutschen Piloten in den letzten Monaten
über der Ostsee die Transponder auf
deaktiviert so sieht die Bedrohung des
Baltischen Luftraums aus
gemeinsam mit seinem amerikanischen
Kollegen low und der us-botschafterin
Goodman macht der deutsche
Luftwaffenchef heute klar wo die Grenze
verläuft die Grenze die Russland nicht
überschreiten sollte
wir zeigen das genau dieses Natrium
unsere rote Linie ist dass wir bereit
sind jeden Zentimeter dieses
Territoriums zu verteidigen Herr
Defender 2023 soll eine Demonstration
der Stärke sein hier im Fliegerhorst
Wunstorf in Niedersachsen ist der
zentrale umschlagort für Materialien
Versorgung für das größte
luftwaffenmanöver der Geschichte 25
Nationen darunter auch nicht NATO-Länder
wie Schweden oder Japan 10.000 Soldaten
250 verschiedene Flugzeuge
Elisabeth es geht um die Bereitschaft
unserer Kräfte es geht um Koordination
nicht nur in der NATO sondern auch
gerade mit unseren Partnern außerhalb
des Bündnisses
bis zur reibungslosen kerosinversorgung
wird geübt wie Ernst der Westen die
Bedrohung durch Russland nimmt
die politische Botschaft dieser
Großübung richtet sich an ihn an
Vladimir Putin die us-botschafterin
verpackt diplomatisch eine ziemlich
klare Warnung an den Kremmel
ich wäre schon sehr überrascht wenn
irgendein Staatsoberhaupt der Welt nicht
zur Kenntnis nehmen würde was dies in
Bezug auf die Einstellung des Bündnisses
in Bezug auf die Stärke des Bündnisses
bedeutet
das schließt Herrn Putin ein
das beeindruckt sie dürfen ja nicht
vergessen vor Beginn des Krieges hat die
NATO des 20-fache verrüstung und Armeen
ausgegeben hat ihn auch nicht gestört ja
trotzdem seinen Völkerrecht für den
Krieg gestartet und ich finde wir
müssten versuchen den Weg der
Deeskalation zu gehen zehn Tage lang
wird in drei Luft Gebieten geübt im
Osten im Norden und im Süden zeitlich
versetzt und jeweils auf vier Stunden am
Tag begrenzt trainiert werden abfangen
Operationen luftkriegsszenarien und die
Kommunikation untereinander dass dies
auch zu Störungen im zivilen Bereich
führen kann sei der Preis heißt es heute
wenn wir demonstrieren wollen dass wir
in der Lage sind dieses Land und dieses
Bündnis zu verteidigen dann müssen wir
das eben für diesen kurzen Zeitraum
diese zehn Tage aus 365 Tage auch
hinnehmen man kann auch sagen Sicherheit
gibt es eben auch nicht zu Nulltarif das
ist aber zu massiven zivilen
Flugausfällen kommt will sich der
General lieber nicht vorstellen er hofft
auf wenige Verspätungen allenfalls im
Minutenbereich
der Westen trainiert für den Ernstfall
für die Ukraine ist der ja längst
grausame Realität und die Kampfflugzeuge
die von der NATO vorgeführt werden hätte
sie gerne in großer Stückzahl selbst
wird mit ihrer Offensive aber wohl nicht
warten können bis tatsächlich welche
geliefert werden
Präsident selenski äußerte sich heute
zurückhaltend dazu inwieweit die
ukrainische Offensive nun noch durch die
Flutkatastrophe erschwert oder verzögert
wird
die Bilder die uns aus der Ukraine
erreichen sind jedenfalls schlimm und
das leidvolle eigene Erfahrung etwa mit
der Flut im Ahrtal oder der oder Flut
wissen wir hierzulande ja nur zu gut was
solche Hochwasserkatastrophen bedeuten
und das dann auch noch in einem
Kriegsgebiet Christian von Rechenberg
berichtet
der Militär-LKW sollte sie rausholen
doch er kommt nicht weiter das Wasser
ist stärker der Wagen steckt fest eine
Odyssee irgendwo in Hessen Hilfe kommt
mit dem Amphibienfahrzeug
die Boote nimmt es gleich mit gut
gegangen eine Geschichte von
zahnlosenamt neopro wo sie gegen das
Wasser kämpfen
und gegen die Zeit
gut dass die Jungs gekommen sind und
gerettet haben uns geholfen haben ohne
sie werden wir jetzt nicht hier
eine Flutkatastrophe direkt an der Front
auf der anderen Seite des Flusses sind
russische Stellungen dort donnern die
Geschöpfe der Krieg kennt keine Gnade
keine Pause in Sicherheit sind die
Menschen hier nie
und die Tiere können sich allein nicht
in Sicherheit bringen die Tierrettung
kümmert sich irina hat heute schon 30
Hunde gerettet sagt sie mehr passen
nicht in den Wagen
wir warten jetzt auf ein Boot damit wir
uns auf den Weg machen können um noch
mehr Tiere leben rauszuholen
leben aber wie nach dieser Katastrophe
was die Fluten stehen lassen ist
einsturzgefährdet oder unbewohnbar
überall treiben Minen überall sind Öl
Chemikalien der ukrainische
Innenminister ist in Person um sich ein
Bild zu machen
wenn die chemischen Abfälle ins Schwarze
Meer gelangen wird das eine Katastrophe
nicht nur für die Ukraine sondern für
den ganzen Schwarzmeerraum
ist von der anderen Seite mit ihrer
Mutter rübergekommen von den Russen
wollte sie sich nicht retten lassen sie
ist mit dem eigenen Boot übergesetzt
die Russen sind gestern abgezogen wir
haben dann alle in der zweiten Etage
übernachtet das Wasser stieg aber bis
dahin und dann haben wir den Fluss auf
eigenes Risiko überquert
wo Anfang wo aufhören überall in der
Stadt sind noch Menschen eingeschlossen
ältere vor allem überall gehen
Freiwillige an ihre Grenzen und weiter
Svetlana muss zurück in ihre Wohnung die
Papiere sind noch dort zwei junge Männer
bringen Sie hin dorthin wo man ihr zu
Hause war für sie das schönste weit und
breit
und nun
im hohen Alter
bekam ich ein Geschenk dass ich nicht
schlafen kann
dass ich nicht essen kann und nicht mehr
meine Wohnung komme
schwarzer Humor was sonst bleibt den
Menschen in Person am Tag eins nach der
Katastrophe
entscheiden wir noch zu unserem Reporter
Tim Kröger Tim wie ist jetzt am Abend in
Hassan
also wir waren hier bis zur Dämmerung in
den tiefergelegenen Stadtteilen von
razon dort wo das Wasser steht und dort
haben jetzt am Abend die Rettungskräfte
ihre Boote und ihre Spezialfahrzeuge aus
dem Wasser geholt und ich nehme an dass
diese Menschen die da geholfen haben
sich jetzt erst einmal ein bisschen
ausruhen werden denn das war ein
ziemlich langer Tag wir haben im Grunde
schon am frühen Morgen angefangen mit
den eberkuierungen das waren vor allem
oft ältere Menschen die sie aus
Wohnungen herausgeholt haben die eben
von dem Wassermassen eingeschlossen
waren und diese älteren Menschen hatten
dann eben ganz oft einfach nur ein paar
Habseligkeiten dabei viele hatten ihre
Haustiere dabei und jetzt weiß im Grunde
keiner wann diese Menschen wirklich in
ihre Wohnung zurückkehren können dafür
aber fand ich den Umgang der Menschen
mit dieser Situation wirklich
bewundernswert viele waren sehr gefasst
wirken sehr gefasst und ja der ruhig in
dieser Situation und die haben uns auch
gesagt dass sie jetzt schon so viel in
Kasern in dieser Stadt in den
vergangenen Monaten erlebt haben dass
sie jetzt in dieser Situation ganz
bestimmt nicht aufgeben und wenn man
sich vorstellt was die Menschen in den
vergangenen Monaten hier durchgemacht
hat dann frage ich mich wirklich woher
sie die Kraft nehmen also das war schon
sehr beeindruckend dass heute hier zu
erleben und rund um Dich gibt's jede
Menge hundegeheult
ja das sind hier ein paar streuende
Hunde das ist hier über einen Carson so
auch in einer Großstadt in diesen
Kriegstagen Tim vielen Dank alles Gute
nach Hassan
das Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe ist
mit seinen ukrainischen Partnern im
Überschwemmungsgebiet aktiv wenn Sie die
Helfer unterstützen möchten können Sie
spenden Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine
IBAN
de65-100 400 600-100 400 600 alle Infos
auch unter spenden.zdf.de
die Zeitenwende die mit diesem
Angriffskrieg einhergeht bedeutet für
Deutschland militärisch nicht nur dass
die Bundeswehr aus und aufgerüstet
werden soll sie führt auch zu einer
Neuausrichtung in der Rüstungspolitik
gegenüber anderen Staaten Thomas
Reichert gleich berichtet der den
Bundesverteidigungsminister auf
Dienstreise nach Indien begleitet hat
kurz gesagt könnte man es so formulieren
man will Russland rüstungspolitisch
nicht länger das Feld überlassen
im Militärhafen von Mumbai warten zwei
Dinge auf Boris Pistorius erstens eine
Marine Mütze die ist gut gegen die Hitze
und ein russisches Kriegsschiff das ist
gut dass Erinnerung daran warum es ihm
hier geht Pistorius hat Deutschlands
Zeiten wenn dem Gepäck der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine soll folgen
haben für die deutsche Politik in Asien
die Zurückhaltung bei beispielsweise der
Lieferung von Waffen und anderen
Material hat dazu geführt dass Indien
wie andere Länder auch sich sehr
orientieren mussten aus ihrer
Perspektive nach Russland zum Beispiel
und jetzt finden wir zusammen und 60%
der Waffen Indiens kommen aus Russland
es hat Putins Krieg gegen die Ukraine
auch deshalb bislang nicht verurteilt
aber indien will sich unabhängiger
machen
überlegene Waffensysteme sie haben eine
bessere Qualität und eine bessere
Technologie und deshalb hat Indien jetzt
da ist ein Militär modernisieren will
ein Interesse daran in den Ziele aber
ist am Ende seine eigene Technologie zu
entwickeln am späten Nachmittag kommt
Pistorius in Mumbai zur mother gone
Werft und findet gleich Anschluss
erliebe Deutschland sagt der
Chefingenieur habe dort auch mal
studiert das fügt sich gut denn die
Werft hat gerade einen Vorvertrag
unterschrieben mit ThyssenKrupp über dem
Bau von 6 U-Booten Indien ist zunächst
mal offen sie machen Geschäfte mit
nahezu allen Nationen dieser Welt und
ich glaube das ist gut wäre wenn wir sie
stärker auch an Deutschland binden
können zum Beispiel mit solchen großen
Auftritt in Indonesien geht es kurz
zuvor um etwas ähnliches zweimal A400M
bitte heißt es dort die militärische
Transportmaschine historius würde sagen
ja gerne aber die Entscheidung liegt
offenbar seit Monaten im
Wirtschaftsministerium historius will
dass das schneller geht und so testet
der Verteidigungsminister in Fernost
nicht nur die alten Grenzen der Rüstungs
sondern die der Außenpolitik gleich mit
bei Indonesien vor allem aber bei Indien
ich finde beispielsweise das ist gut
wäre wenn wir den Weg finden die
Behandlung Indiens dem anzugleichen wie
Japan und Australien behandelt werden
der indische Verteidigungsminister
findet das gut denn die Hürden für
rüstungsdienst mit Deutschland wären
damit erheblich niedriger für
Deutschland wäre es ein massiver
Kurswechsel ein Warnsignal nicht nur in
Russland sondern auch an Indiens Rivalen
China unsere Unterstützung richten sich
nicht gegen irgendeinen anderen Akteur
hier in der Region weder gegen China
noch gegen Pakistan noch sonst irgendwie
gegen irgendjemand es geht darum
diejenigen Partner die wir haben in der
Region dabei zu unterstützen sich
selbstverteidigen zu können was
Pistorius zurück bringt ist also eine
Art Zeitenwende Fernost was er dafür
noch braucht ist die Unterstützung zu
Hause
mit dem Blick in die USA beginnen jetzt
bei dir die Nachrichten hat dort wird es
fällt der Bewerber um die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur bei den
Republikanern immer größer zu den
Konkurrenten von Ex-Präsident Trump
gehört nun auch dessen damaliger Vize
Mike Pants er hat heute in seinem 64
Geburtstag seine Bewerbung offiziell
gestartet bei einer Rede in Iowa
kritisierte Pants Präsident beiden und
distanzierte sich auch von Trump in den
Umfragen liegt unter den
republikanischen Bewerbern Trump bislang
vorne
die EU-Kommission eröffnet ein neues
Verfahren gegen Polen wegen eines
umstrittenen Gesetzes es geht darum dass
eine Untersuchungskommission prüfen soll
ob Amtsträger in den vergangenen Jahren
unter russischem Einfluss Entscheidungen
getroffen haben die der Sicherheit
Polens geschadet haben kritiker werfen
der Regierung vor damit vor den
anstehenden Parlamentswahlen
Oppositionspolitiker wie den früheren
Ministerpräsidenten Tusk in Misskredit
bringen zu wollen
Papst franziskus hat sich eine
dringenden Operation am Bauch unterzogen
zunehmende Beschwerden als Folgen einer
früheren Operation machten den Eingriff
notwendig am Morgen hatte franziskus
noch die allwöchentliche Audienz auf dem
Petersplatz zelebriert erst danach ließ
sich der 86-Jährige in das
timely-krankenhaus bringen laut Vatikan
verlief die Operation unter Vollnarkose
ohne Komplikationen
die Bundesregierung hat ein Gesetz auf
den Weg gebracht dass die Investitionen
in das Schienennetz vorantreiben soll
der Bund soll mehr Spielräume bei der
Finanzierung bekommen und sich auch an
den Kosten der Unterhaltung und
Instandhaltung beteiligen können in dem
Gesetzentwurf von Verkehrsminister
Wissing heißt es der
modernisierungsrückstaus sei groß und
dessen Beseitigung keinen Aufschub
es sah so aus als würde sich die Lage
beruhigen doch jetzt breitet sich der
Waldbrand in Jüterbog südlich von Berlin
wieder aus starker Wind hat den Brand
nach Angaben der Einsatzleitung heute
Vormittag wieder angefacht 90
Einsatzkräfte sind am Ort das Gebiet ist
als ehemaliger Truppenübungsplatz stark
munitionsbelastet was die Löscharbeiten
erschwert das Feuer brennt schon seit
mitte vergangener Woche
in Nürnberg wurde heute der Evangelische
Kirchentag eröffnet bis zu 100.000
Besucher werden erwartet ein riesen
Event doch der Kirchen Alltag sieht ja
anders aus im letzten Jahr traten so
viele Menschen aus der Kirche aus wie
nie zuvor allein bei der evangelischen
waren es 380.000 das was manche aus der
katholischen Kirche treibt Rolle der
Frau die jüngsten Missbrauchskandale
kann auf den ersten Blick als Erklärung
schwerlich herhalten allerdings gab es
im Zuge katholischer Missbrauchskandale
die in München oder Köln jeweils auch in
der evangelischen Kirche aus Trotz
Wellen die negativ Wirkung scheint da
sozusagen über zu springen oder bietet
zumindest einen Anlass aber auch das
erklärt nicht warum es insgesamt so
viele Austritte gibt ein Thema das auch
auf dem Kirchentag nicht ausgeblendet
werden kann Patricia Schäfer berichtet
aus Nürnberg
der 38 Deutsche Evangelische Kirchentag
ist eröffnet
überschwängliche Freude auf dem
Nürnberger Hauptmarkt auch in den
angrenzenden Straßen stehen die Menschen
dicht gedrängt um irgendwie dabei zu
sein einer von ihnen Alexander Brandl
Fahrrad der olympiakirche in München
auf den ersten Blick natürlichen
wahnsinnig imposantes Bild
wenn ich zu Hause meine Kirchengemeinde
sich meine ich kenne die Zahlen ganz
einfach und und die sprechende klare
Sprache
380.000 Menschen sind im vergangenen
Jahr aus der evangelischen Kirche
ausgetreten ein Drittel mehr als im Jahr
zuvor also ich weiß von vielen Leuten
dass es einfach wirklich an euch hier
von Steuer auch liegt das sind Menschen
in meinem Alter die kommt auf den ersten
Gehaltszettel merken oh das ist ganz
schön viel was die von mir wollen und
dann schätze ich eben die Frage spielt
die Kirche eine große Rolle oder sagen
Sie nee das ist das Geld nicht wert 8
bzw 9% der zu zahlenden Einkommenssteuer
treten Kirchenmitglieder in Deutschland
an die Institution Kirche ab je nach
Wohnort ob das auch in Zukunft so sein
soll darüber macht sich selbst
kirchentagspräsident Thomas Gedanken
wenn es von den Kirchen selbst aktiv
eine Debatte darüber gibt gibt es andere
Modelle der Finanzierung der Kirchen die
aber auch etwas mehr als einen
spendencharakter haben sollten da kann
man sich ja in Europa umgucken da gibt
es interessante Modelle diese
Diskussionen würde ich begrüßen lebhafte
Diskussionen wird es auf den Kirchentag
geben Klimagerechtigkeit über
Generationengerechtigkeit über den
Ukraine Krieg und die Frage können
Christen für Waffenlieferungen sein der
Bundespräsident mit einer klaren Meinung
es ist auch Zeit für Waffen wir alle
wollen ein Ende des Schreckens wir
wollen ein Ende des Krieges wir wollen
Frieden
aber es muss doch liebe Schwestern und
Brüder ein gerechter Friede sein und
klar ist doch wenn Russland seine
Soldaten zurückzieht dann ist der Krieg
zu Ende wenn die Ukraine ihre
Verteidigung einstellt dann ist das das
Ende der Ukraine liebe Schwestern und
Brüder und noch ein Thema wird prägend
sein die Kritik des
kirchentagspräsidenten an der Generation
Z die zu viel an sich selbst und zu
wenig an die Gesellschaft denke dem
widerspricht neben Pfarrer Brandl auch
Anna Nicole Heinrich 27 und Präses der
IKD ein Generationenkonflikt gibt es den
wirklich ist die bumer Generation die
die genervt ist von der Generation Z ich
muss ganz klar sagen ich Teil dieses
Statement nicht die jungen Menschen die
ich waren eben gerade die die jetzt ins
Berufsleben starten sind gerade nach
dieser coronazeit so oft unter die Räder
gekommen und ich glaube dass wir dass
sie alles recht haben nachzufragen wie
Leben und Arbeit miteinander vereinbar
sind auch das gehört zum Kirchen Tag
offene Auseinandersetzung nicht immer
einer Meinung sein aber alles in einem
gemeinschaftlichen Geist und Wohlwollen
und bei Hans geht es jetzt mit
Wirtschaft weiter heute gab es neue
Zahlen zur Wirtschaftslage in China
interessant war neben einem unerwartet
starken Einbruch bei den Exporten ein
deutlicher Anstieg beim Handel Chinas
mit Russland Frank bedmann in welchen
wirtschaftlichen Bereichen liegen da die
gegenseitigen Interessen ja er ist
jüngst unterschrieben bei der Staaten
Absichtserklärungen aus den klar
hervorgeht dass man die Zusammenarbeit
noch weiter intensivieren möchte beim
Export von landwirtschaftlichen
Produkten beispielsweise dabei floriert
der gegenseitige Handel bereits jetzt
Russlands Öl und Erdgas Lieferungen nach
China sind seit dem Krieg mit der
Ukraine deutlich gestiegen im Gegenzug
exportiert die Volksrepublik
mittlerweile verstärkt Lastwagen und
andere Nutzfahrzeuge nach Russland auch
Telefone und Computer liefert Peking wie
sich generell sagen lässt dass weitest
in isolierte moskau ist weit stärker auf
den massiven Ausbau der
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen angewiesen ganz
einfach weil China Optionen hat und Gas
beispielsweise künftig auch aus
talkministan beziehen will nun gibt es
ja umfassende Sanktionen gegen Russland
wie bezahlt Moskau das eigentlich alles
ja beide Staaten rechnen ihren
Warenaustausch zunehmend mehr in
johannab an die chinesische Währung
kommt Moskau sehr viel einfacher als an
den US-Dollar den Zugang zur
ausländischen Devisenreserven hat der
Westen durch seine Sanktionen ja
weitgehend blockiert der Johannes damit
praktisch zur Reservewährung für
Russland geworden davon profitiert
Peking ebenfalls versucht es doch den
Johann als ernsthafte Alternative zum
US-Dollar in die Welt zu positionieren
Frank Wittmann vielen Dank
zum Sport zuerst zum Tennis alex hat bei
den French Open das Viertelfinale gegen
den Argentinien gewonnen und steht damit
erneut in Paris im Halbfinale
brüllt Alexander Zverev am Ende seine
Freude heraus zuvor hat der deutsche mit
einem starken ersten Aufschlag das
Viertelfinale gewonnen
ich weiß einfach nicht was ich sagen
soll ich bin einfach glücklich dass ich
weiter bin
insgesamt vier Sätze braucht Zverev
gegen den starken Thomas Martin
im Spiel aber bringt der Argentinien es
wäre oft in Bedrängnis er läuft viele
Bälle und passiert immer wieder von der
Grundlinie
am Ende aber ist es vor allem die
Erfahrung des deutschen die die Partie
zu dessen Gunsten dreht es wäre steht
damit am kommenden Freitag zum dritten
Mal in Folge beim Grand Slam Turnier in
Paris im Halbfinale und ist damit ein
Jahr nach seiner schweren Verletzung am
gleichen Ort zurück in der Weltspitze
tut Bellingham steht vor einem Wechsel
von Borussia Dortmund zu Real Madrid das
gab der BVB heute bekannt die
Ablösesumme für den 19-Jährigen 103
Millionen Euro plus Bonuszahlungen
in Athen ist heute die Flamme entzündet
worden für die Special Olympics die
weltfestspiele für Menschen mit
geistiger und mehrfacher Behinderung
beginnen am 17 Juni in Berlin am 9 Tagen
werden dann über 7000 Athletinnen und
Athleten aus 190 Ländern in 26
Sportarten antreten und auch ZDF und ARD
sind live dabei
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 17 19 30 33 40 49 Superzahl 6 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
im Regal des bildungsbürgers und der
Bürgerin darf James Joyce natürlich
nicht fehlen sein Ulisses der Klassiker
gut 1000 Seiten die viele wohl
weitgehend ungelesen auf dem Bücherbord
stehen haben man hat es mal angefangen
aber irgendwie nicht zu Ende gebracht
noch schwerer verdaulich soll sein
letztes Werk sein für eine ganz Wake
sagen jene die es gelesen haben
zu ihnen gehört definitiv an seinem
Kiefer er hat es nicht nur gelesen
sondern durchgearbeitet durchgegrübelt
und mit seiner Kunst verbunden eine
aufsehenerregende Ausstellung in London
hat an seinem Kiefer dort getroffen
es ist so dunkel im Korridor der
Londoner White Cube Gallery dass der
Künstler im Gegenlicht fast nicht zu
erkennen ist geradezu in den Hintergrund
tritt
in den Regalen rechts und links des
Gangs ein Arsenal ein wundersamen
Gegenständen
mit Labeln in einer noch wundersameren
Sprache
[Musik]
es ist die Sprache des irischen
Schriftstellers James Joyce in dessen
Roman finnegans Wake ein in Augen vieler
unlesbares Werk aber es gibt weniger in
der sich ansellen Kiefer nicht
herantrauen würde dann habe ich dann
angefangen angefangen habe zu studieren
habe ich finde ganz weg mir vorgenommen
und das war immer wieder eine
Enttäuschung weil ich habe das nicht
geschafft habe allerdings dann gedacht
wenn der bäckert den den ich nicht
kannte wenn der das so toll findet dann
muss ich mich noch mal dran machen dann
darf ich nicht aufgeben ich habe auch
nicht aufgegeben und ähm hab da dann
viel mehr verstanden über die Sprache
und hier die Sprache demoliert wie er
sie wieder aufbaut und so weiter und
damit hört die Seelenverwandtschaft mit
Joyce auch noch nicht auf wie eine
parallel Aktion zum zum weg
weil ich der hat ja unheimlich lange
daran gearbeitet immer wieder verworfen
hat sich wieder umgebaut das war nie
fertig eigentlich und so sind sind meine
Bilder auch nicht fertig also alles was
Sie hier sehen das kann auch in zehn
Jahren damals sein
die Farbgebung insgesamt ist ähnlich
düster wie der Korridor doch ein Saal
sticht heraus
diese Bilder sind alle entstanden
aufgrund von Fotos die ich im Alltag
gemacht habe ich bin am Altrhein
aufgewachsen bin dadurch die Tümpel
gegangen hat dort geschwommen und so
weiter und es hat ein ganz bestimmtes
bestimmter Erinnerung für mich dieser
diese altrheinlandschaft und die habe
ich jetzt da hin gebaut als ein spielung
an liefern den an den den Fluss der
immer beim Berg von immer vorhanden ist
aber wenn sie jetzt sagen monete stört
mich überhaupt nicht
Kiefer wäre nicht Kiefer wenn es nicht
Anknüpfungen gäbe an die aktuellen Zeit
läuft dürfte komplexe Zeiten wie er
betont mit Krisen und Kriegen
umgekippte Einkaufswagen als Symbol der
Globalisierung alles ist konstante
Transformation
wie gesagt demolieren und wieder
aufbauen
und wenn sie noch ein bisschen in London
bleiben wollen gleich im Ausland schon
mal gibt es eine Reportage darüber warum
sich London praktisch keiner mehr
leisten kann und wie sich das auf die
Stadt auswirkt und um 0:30 Uhr meldet
sich dann Christopher Wehrmann mit
unseren heute journal Update auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend Schauer und Gewitter brachte
dieses kleine tiefen mit das hier von
Ost nach West über uns hinweggezogen ist
morgen zieht es gleich wieder zurück es
gibt heute Abend aber keine Gewitter
mehr in der Nacht werden die mehr und
mehr sich zusammenfallen ganz natürlich
noch einige Regenschauer in Thüringen
oder in Sachsen zu erwarten häufig ist
es auch klar und hier im Nordwesten oder
auch an Saar und Mosel bildet sich etwas
Nebel die Temperaturen sinken auf Werte
zwischen 15 und 7 Grad morgen ist es an
der Küste sehr sonnig Richtung
Mittelgebirge werden die Wolken schon
dichter und in den Mittelgebirge und den
Süddeutschland entwickeln sich zum Teil
heftige Schauer und Gewitter und da
diese Gewitter nur ganz langsam ziehen
können Sie örtlich eng begrenzt auch
stark Regen mitbringen die Gewitter
gefasst etwas geringer im Südwesten am
Oberrhein oder auch im Saarland die
Temperaturen liegen morgen an den Küsten
nach 18 bis 27 Grad in Süddeutschland
sind es 22 bis 28 Grad hier im Nordosten
könnte es morgen für den ersten heißen
Tag in Deutschland reichen also für
Höchsttemperaturen von 70 Grad oder mehr
und damit ist es bei uns wärmer als zum
Beispiel auf den Kanarischen Inseln in
Spanien in Teilen von Italien in der
Griechenland oder auch in der Türkei und
in dieser wetterkonstellation wird sich
bis zum Wochenende nur wenig ändern wir
haben es immer noch mit dem Tiefe dem
Atlantik und dem Hoch über Skandinavien
zu tun das bedeutet für uns hier in
Deutschland viel Sonnenschein Schauer
und Gewitter beschränken sich auf den
Süden und Südosten guten Abend